ma che succede a berlino
lo vedi anche tu un coniglio berlino più
coniglio andiamo a controllare berlino
andiamo un coniglio signor coniglio ma
cosa e quando il mio giardino
ho capito sei venuto qua per darmi tutte
le uova di pasqua vero o no aspetta
spiegami perchè per piatti nel mio
giardino che cosa vuoi da me se
riuscirai a trovare perché circa la
nuova che casco arai vinto la carinzia
sarò lì a trovare te deserto trim1
rimaste se di trento scadenza si ritrova
scappare
berlino berlino ragazzi avete capito
bene il coniglio cattivo vuole che trovi
5 uova di pasqua ma non devo essere
presa a quanto pare o solo una vita in
questa challenge diventano sempre più
difficili queste challenge comunque
vediamo se riusciamo a trovare tutte e
cinque le uova di pasqua mi raccomando
fate il tifo per me e ne siete un bel mi
piace su questo video se volete vedere
altre challenge e se non mi seguite
ancora se saremmo andati a seguirmi il
nome di the stories
siete pronti avete preso i pop corn e
ove cioccolato in questo caso è più a
tema al cioccolato va bene
iniziamo subito come sempre iniziamo la
ricerca qua in cameretta per chi in
genere siamo fortunati e troviamo sempre
qualcosa qua ne troviamo sempre qualcosa
quando i pupazzi iscrivetevi anche voi
se trovate qualche uovo ecco qua ho
trovato il primo uovo di pasqua crudi
non vedo l'ora di vedere cosa ceco ha
detto mi è venuta un'idea
siccome il coniglio ha detto che se mi
prende poi si mangerà tutte le uova di
pasqua
io le apro già quindi ogni volta che mi
trovo una la apro già e vedo che
sorpresa c'è e poi nascondo il
cioccolato così almeno non potrà
mangiarlo
iniziamo subito ad aprire questa ok
apriamo il nostro strino nuovo
rompiamo lui dell'uomo c'è un pozzetto
del gattino apriamolo subito vediamo
come il solo dimenticato di dirvi che il
mio libro è ora scontato su amazon ed è
un ottimo regalo per pasqua ci sono
tanti fai da te e risente slime
challenge e fatemi sapere nei commenti
se lo avete preso bilancio il link in
descrizione eccolo qua carinissimo è un
mini trudi in miniatura classe il fondo
lino con scritto 3d ed è un gattino che
seduto penso si che carino il piace un
sacco ma ora andiamo a cercare le altre
uova di pasqua e alla fine del video
potrete scrivere nei commenti qual è la
sorpresa che vi è piaciuta più di tutte
sono uscita nuovamente in giardino
perché siccome ho incontrato il coniglio
qui l'ultima volta penso che lui abbia
nascosto delle uova di pasqua qui quindi
contro chiamo bene assieme diavolaccio
il coniglio è la prima volta che l'ho
visto dalla finestra era quaggiù quindi
forse ha nascosto qualcosa in mezzo alle
piante
non c'è niente
come farò
ma sbaglio c'è qualcosa di rosa là in
mezzo la vedete anche voi non ci credo
erano scorso qua dietro ferrari morti e
molti posto molto bene abbiamo già
provato il mio prospettando un nuovo
senza problemi
per poco sia mancato pochissimo che ci
prendesse dovevi fare tutto in questo
vuoto
apriamo lo vediamo questo troviamo
dentro che andiamo ad aprire questo
robot
se giochiamo come
guardate quel suo pendant ferrosa il
cioccolato rosa bellissimo tutti dentro
gli apre e indistruttibile questo nuovo
ok ce l'ho fatta dentro c'è o ci sono
due basi rosa ovviamente
e poi c'è un ciondolino con scritto
buona pasqua e ci sono due sterline
che carino voglio assaggiare questo
cioccolato rosa e vedere che sapore ha
proviamo a un po un sapore alla ciliegia
tipo è molto dolce sembra un po fruttato
proviamo ora a controllare nell'altra
camera
simili
vedete
ho trovato un altro uomo
guardatevi il nuovo chi parti frozen 28
potuti vedere c'è mancato poco sono
dovute a saltare sopra letto per
scappare al coniglio malefico pa sono
fatta filtrati ma è tutto quel tempo va
bene ora avremo quest'uomo e vediamo che
sorpresa troviamo dentro
andiamo ad aprire il terzo uomo ne
mancano solo due forse possiamo parte
spero di trovare ora abbiamo trovato
anna andiamo montarlo vediamo come ecco
qua e anna con la renna che non mi
ricordo se come si chiama se si chiama
rodolfo non mi ricordo nel call accordo
ok andiamo a trovare le altre due uova
ragazzi avuto un'idea geniale
forse l'avete già intravisto
praticamente quando il coniglio proverà
a prendermi io gli tirerò ma questa una
semplicissima carota ma i coni libia
sono le carote vero almeno spero che a
questo coniglio strano piacciano le
carote e un po un po strana questa carta
è un po strana comunque spero che questo
piano funzioni perché se il pontano solo
due stiamo per vincere mi raccomando
lasciato mi piace se volete il continuo
belli invece
[Musica]
e un buonissimo succosissimo parola ha
funzionato il piano funzionato come
riuscita a prendere nuovo di strangolo
andiamo ad aprire il nostro quarto uomo
spero che capiterà un cagnolino un
cagnolino che somiglia a berlino è bello
berlino e qua dietro che osserva perché
un curioso ne vediamo un po che lo è se
troviamo qua dentro un altro gattino che
carino un gattino grigio pur i corrotti
un po apriamolo è carinissimo quindi
abbiamo già due gattini peluche
vediamo gli altri a questo è il gatto
certosino che carino andiamo ora a
cercare l'ultimo uomo che sicuramente
sarà il più difficile
berlino vuole assolutamente che gli dove
il gattino mi sta pregando facendomi gli
occhi dolci ma se io gli do questo
gattino merlino lui lo fa il mille pezzi
perché berlino distrugge tutti i peluche
non posso mai dati nessun peluche yo per
club ai mille pezzi
adesso tutto il cotone nome dispiace
berlino non posso dartelo fatemi sapere
se anche i vostri candolini distruggono
tutti i peluche
ok ragazzi fermiamo il corridoio perché
non perché non mi vuoi far passare
bloccato le mi vuoi dire qualcosa
scusa berlino e domandare di qua devo
trovare l'ultimo luogo forse tua dietro
c'è qualcosa
entra
aspettiamo un po vediamo se esce mai
fatto capolino sotto lanciano 1 0
vediamo cosa sta combinando coniglio
nella mia cameretta e con un luogo
vicino forse una trappola ma quello e lo
stimo buffon guarda te ce l'ha nessuno
taschini dobbiamo prenderlo piano piano
non ce l'abbiamo fatta
devo scusare un altro piano ho un piano
allora ho preso altre carte metterò
delle carote all'entrata nella porta
della cameretta
così il coniglio federale carote spero
oppure dovrò lanciarli né qualcuno
addosso se non le vede e andrà a
prendere le carote questi magari si
distrae e io riesco a rubare luogo
[Musica]
eccolo è ancora rispetto
no no no non sono per te berlino solo
per il coniglio
no troppo davvero troppo il culo per
tirare una carota al cominciò così si
sveglia 3 2 1
bene fino a starmi subito
tua zia funzionato preso l'ultimo uovo e
il coni giusta ma mangiano tutte le
carote per andare a controllare
ora aspetto un po che il coniglio si
allontani per tornare in studio per
aprire l'ultimo uomo
signor coniglio ricorda ho preso
l'ultimo uomo quindi ho vinto la
challenge non puoi farmi più niente
adesso per atene è il casale 0
se questo video raggiunge i 45 mila mi
piace
ritornerò egli associato di gaber e
godibile due modi passo adesso io andro
magari di tutte le carote viene dato ben
è sparito solo abbiamo boccia premura
l'ultimo uomo
ecco quando il suo uovo un altro uomo
crudi
spero che mi capiti qualche cagnolino
questa volta tutto questo ma tutti gli
animali sono bellissimi subito ad
aprirlo
che cosa secondo voi non si capisce
perché tutto schiacciato
penso che sia un coniglietto o un
orsetto un coniglio andiamo ad aprirlo
ecco che carino e un coniglietto based
alle ore che un po più marroncina magari
questo dovevo farlo vedere al coniglio
cattivo
magari poi si impietosì va e si
affezionava a questo coniglietto
pomodori e suo figlio tipo comunque
super morbido del super carino scrivete
nei commenti qual è stata la vostra
sorpresa preferita la mia preferita è
stata il gattino crudi il gattino grigio
era super carino scrivete nei commenti
la vostra preferita e vi ricordo che
trovate il mio libro scontato su amazon
non vi lascio il link qua sotto
in cui potete fare tantissime ricette
fai da te e slime è ora vi lascio qua 4
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]